as we continue tonight on Hannity
joining us now the author of the
best-selling book vengeance Fox News
contributor former Speaker of the House
Newt Gingrich mr. speaker you know is
this a political prosecution you see
unfolding before you in other words you
got you got all of Muller's appointees
for Hillary Clinton we're discovering
all of them with questionable ethical
the the use of their at there's a lack
of ethics and persecuting all Trump
associates do you see something that's
dangerous to you well it's very
dangerous and it's actually very
parallel to what they have just exposed
in Wisconsin was an effort to use the
legal system to destroy Governor Walker
and they have had an amazing series of
stories in Wisconsin now were turned out
that there were group of lawyers who ran
amuck and who were trying to destroy
people's lives I see the same thing
happening here and I raise a single
question how could they possibly go
after general Flynn after 35 years
serving in uniform and skip hillary
clinton's aides who clearly lied under
oath how can they possibly defend that
but now we know the physician it seems
to me that they were writing their
exoneration they didn't even do the
investigation sir
right so so I think the correct answer
under our constitutional system is for
the House and Senate Judiciary
Committee's to start subpoenaing these
guys bringing them in under oath I want
to see all 10,000 of the tweets that the
one FBI agent apparently sent to his
girlfriend that has all sorts of
apparently anti Trump stuff in it but
more than that I think they need to
bring Comey in under oath and say tell
us again why you did not swear in
Hillary Clinton why would she not put at
risk of perjury the way you did the way
general Flynn was I think they need to
bring in the entire team who were
involved in the Clinton investigation
this thing stinks so badly that we
really need to be protected and under
our Constitution one of the protections
is the power of Congress to investigate
and the House and Senate Judiciary
Committee's
I wanted one thing they should ask is
the deputy FBI director whose wife as a
Democratic candidate god I think nine
hundred thousand dollars in donations
why did he not recuse himself how can he
possibly be neutral and these are the
kind of questions the Congress ought to
be asking right now when do we what do
we do if they never really investigated
Hillary Clinton now I mean because we
know the fix was in we know that they
wrote the exoneration beforehand and why
do I think that's obstruction of justice
by call me this guy Peter struck and and
other people that are involved what are
we how do we have equal justice on the
law if we don't do that well I think
clearly the Attorney General has to
appoint a special counsel I think they
need two special counsels one to go back
and look at the entire Clinton
experience the the uranium one the
Clinton Foundation etc but second we
need a special counsel or some kind of
appropriate appointment to review the
FBI and the Justice Department's own
role I mean this is so sick it is so
one-sided it is so clearly not the rule
of law sometimes you have to have
somebody who protects you from the
protectors when the protectors are you
know Lord Acton warned that power tends
to corrupt absolute power corrupts
absolutely we are living through that
experience right now we're seeing power
in the Justice Department power and the
FBI that clearly led to corruption and
that means we've got to take some very
severe steps it may involve frankly
developing some panels of special
outside lawyers who have the full power
to subpoena everything to go in and just
route this stuff out I mean it's this is
really a serious serious problem it's
also a serious problem if you have a
group of people that want to undo an
election do you believe at the heart of
this that there is a deep state maybe
including former intelligence officials
or people that use the weaponry of
intelligence that are criminalizing
perhaps the FBI deep state leaking that
have as their goal that they think the
American people made its mistake and
they want to
do the results of this election and
they're using every devious tactic they
possibly can
well a good friend of mine who's been
through this and who understands it
really well said to me today you have to
understand that in 2016 the idea of
Donald Trump as president was so
horrifying to the left that any action
was seen as acceptable no matter how
illegal as long as it was for the
purpose of stopping Trump and I think
they all frankly expected Hillary to win
and they thought they would simply cover
up all of their crimes the great shock
to them has been the Trump did win and
that's slowly painfully step-by-step we
are beginning to unmask how sick the
system is how deep the corruption is and
a lot of people are now at risk I think
I think molars at risk I think commis at
risk I think there are a whole range of
people were at risk for having basically
violated the law abused power and in
remarkable ways that I don't know of any
experience in American history where you
have the scale of abuse of power that
we're seeing right now
the boomerang effect though is in full
play here because we now know Hillary
Clinton through her campaign through the
DNC which Donna Brazile says she
controlled and the money they're in that
they paid fusion gps that they that they
hired this guy Christopher Steele
Christopher steel goes forward and in
fact uses and pays Russians for lies
about Donald Trump all to influence an
election and there is the possibility as
it came up in the hearing today with Jim
Jordan that in fact that phony Russian
propaganda lying dossier was used as the
basis to get a FISA warrant against
either candidate or and or candidate
Trump and president elect Trump and his
team now if that were to be the case
which it appears it may very well be a
possibility after the hearings today
what does that mean well what it means
is that the Obama administration did
everything it could first to block Trump
from winning and second to undermine and
weaken and Trump as he took
power and that this is ultimately going
to go all the way through the entire
Minister
it's the National Security Adviser it's
the sense the ambassador to the United
Nations it's a whole range of people
it's the Attorney General and I think
people need to recognize this this is an
extraordinarily wide-ranging pattern of
corruption I mean corruption and that
not in a sense of money swapping hands
but in the old-fashioned sense that the
founding fathers would have understood
that these were people who were abusing
the law for their special interest and
the special interest of their faction
and they were prepared to hurt the
innocent they were prepared to frame
people they're prepared to do whatever
they had to because they believed that
the cause they were for was so
self-righteous the cause of defeating
Trump even more than the cause of
electing Hillary it was the specter of
Trump that terrified him and therefore
anything was legitimate now it wasn't it
was in fact illegal all right we got to
leave it there mr. speaker always good
to see you thank you for being with us